im politischen herzen der stadt im
regierungsviertel von rom entlädt sich
die verzweiflung zimmer hilfen
kellnerinnen personal von hotels und
gastronomie oft ohne tarifvertrag zum
teil schwarz beschäftigt sie waren die
ersten die ihren job verloren
[Musik]
corona trifft sie besonders hart
oft fehlt die soziale absicherung
sie haben uns das recht auf arbeit
genommen die würde
wir haben nicht mal mehr tränen zum
weinen wir haben nicht mal mehr ein euro
um uns brot zu kaufen ich habe drei
töchter
es steht dass die krise im
gesundheitswesen groß ist aber die
wirtschaftliche und soziale krise ist
noch viel schlimmer
hier sind 10.000 leute mit familien
frauen und kinder
die verzweiflung treibt uns auf die
straße ihr hättet ihr abo ich öffne
auch giorgio rocky ist dabei der 50
jährige familienvater protestiert für
die öffnung seines restaurants
es gefällt ihm allerdings nicht als er
merkt dass sich auch neofaschisten von
casa pound und verschwörungstheoretiker
der grünen bewegung unter die
demonstranten mischen an diesem tag
eskaliert die situation direkt vor dem
parlament dem monte quito rio giorgio
rocky will sich nicht vereinnahmen
lassen trotz seiner prekären lage wir
begleiten ihn zu seinem restaurant
gleich an der piazza san inacio im
historischen zentrum
drinnen wartet der grund für seine
schlaflosen nächte nach über einem jahr
pandemie ist sein restaurant zum dritten
mal in folge geschlossen
statt reservierungen stapeln sich die
rechnungen
obwohl ich geschlossen habe muss ich 712
euro strom bezahlen an fixen kosten lege
ich im monat 17 bis 18.000 euro drauf
und mein restaurants zu
vor neun jahren hat georgia das
restaurant gemietet seitdem waren an
guten tagen alle tische voll besetzt
[Musik]
seine kulinarischen kreationen waren
sehr beliebt
von den einnahmen konnte seine familie
und die seine angestellten einigermaßen
gut leben jetzt sagt er haben sich
300.000 euro schulden angehäuft und mit
jedem tag der schließung rutschen sie
dem abgrund näher
das sind neun jahre harte arbeit
ich habe neun angestellte das heißt
vorher konnte ich mit meinem restaurant
neuen familien ernähren und in zukunft
haben sie keine anstellung
ich bin nur einer von sehr vielen die
gerade in der gleichen situation sind
noch nie war seine angst vor dem abstieg
so groß am römischen tiber ufer ist im
laufe des jahres einen obdachlosen zählt
zum anderen dazu gekommen immer
sichtbarer werden die auswirkungen der
korona pandemie die armut wächst bei der
katholischen hilfsorganisation
sant'egidio spüren sie das ganz konkret
die freiwilligen helfer geben hier
doppelt soviel mahlzeiten aus wie noch
vor der krise erzielt cici japan i
seit einem jahr ist ganz anders die
leute die für ein normaler arbeitsplatz
hatte eine normale wohnung ein normales
leben hatten aber plötzlich alles
verlorene leute die restaurant
gearbeitet haben bei der bauarbeiten so
familien mit kinder die jetzt nichts
mehr zu essen haben und kommen her um
das parkett und zu nehmen
seitdem corona ausbruch vor einem jahr
hat sant'egidio eigenen angaben zufolge
rund 300.000 essenspakete in ganz
italien verteilt
aufgrund der erhöhten nachfrage wurden
neue lebensmittel zentren eröffnet in
neapel turin palermo genua
rom hier begegnen wir vittorio er ist
der einzige der seine scham überwindet
und mit uns spricht
er erzählt uns dass er seinen job als
barmann verlor und seit einiger zeit
wohnungslos ist die regierung macht sich
kein bild davon dass die situation immer
schlimmer wird dass immer mehr leute auf
der straße leben ohne arbeit ohne essen
zu können und das ist definitiv nicht in
ordnung
die regierung legt zwei hilfsprogramme
auf die stadt rom gibt einen
essenszuschuss und andere
sozialleistungen aber besonders in den
wohnquartieren jenseits der historischen
baukunst rom ort ist im viertel
cinecitta wohnt georgia rocky mit seinem
hund seiner frau und den zwei söhnen auf
65 quadratmetern
vormittags ist er allein zu hause die
fernsehnachrichten melden die neuesten
corona zahlen die sich georgia schon gar
nicht mehr ansieht
er organisiert eine neue protestaktion
mit hat angst davor seine wohnung zu
verlieren
ich habe eine ratenzahlung der miete
verhandelt dann musste ich auch diese
unterbrechen
früher oder später befürchte ich eine
zwangsräumung endlos wird dieser
situation sicherlich nicht weitergehen
besonders um die zukunft seiner söhne
macht er sich gedanken der 15 jährige
claudio kommt zum mittag nach hause
wer soll einmal all die schulden
begleichen die privaten und die
exorbitant gestiegenen staatsschulden
italiens aber auch die hilfsbereitschaft
nimmt zu in der krise als es seinem
restaurant hier gegenüber noch gut ging
hat auch giorgio für die armen essen
gespendet in der gemeinde der
jesuitenkirche st die nation rom gibt es
eine warme mahlzeit und eine krone
impfung das essen kommt von der
community vita christiana den impfstoff
für die armen stellt der vatikan zur
verfügung
am circus maximus sammelt sich derweil
die demonstration die georgia mit
organisiert hat diesmal ohne
rechtsextreme und ohne gewalt
stattdessen zeigen sie ihre unterhosen
als symbol für das wenige was ihnen
geblieben ist wir sollen wieder öffnen
und es müsste möglich sein die
verbindlichkeiten zu stunden weil viele
leute in meiner situation die schulden
einfach nicht bezahlen kann
ende des monats hat die regierung
angekündigt sollen nun tagsüber und
vorerst nur draußen geöffnet werden
dürfen
doch das reicht auch georgia nicht er
meldet sich anfang der woche von der a
45 bei perugia
aus wut und verzweiflung haben sie damit
begonnen die wichtige verkehrsader
zwischen der adria und rom zu blockieren
[Musik]